les chéris moi je suis désolé je sais
pas pour vous franchement il est 21h30
huit mois j'ai super fin alors
franchement noir est énorme et arrêter
de croire que centre de toutes les
années oui bonsoir monsieur bonsoir
attendu 8e oui bonsoir
bonjour qu'est ce qui se passe alors oui
le livre avait déjà arrivé que j'ai faim
ça veut dire ça comme ça c'est arrête
d'être lourd dont tu te retournes merci
les chéris donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
j'ai une livraison apparemment une
livraison
ben alors c'est adorable mais moi j'ai
pas j'ai pas encore commandé j'ai juste
dit j'avais faim bas nous on écoute et
on magie alors si tu veux tu peux tu
peux rester un peu avec nous dieu mais
en fait je n'en sais rien comment donc
pas pourquoi tu préfères par tu préfères
page et mon patron dans le public
ton patron il est dans le public ton
patron là il est dans public tout à vous
faire il est où ton patron les la balle
elle des lunettes noires où ça ou ça un
opus effet l'amnésie qu'ils aient
connaît plus on salariale et ça marche
il est autant pas juste là c'est ça
c'est vous oui c'est luc bonnet bonnet
monsieur venait abonnés
[Applaudissements]
attendez à paris un salarié s'est on a
oublié ma tête c'est vrai monsieur est
ce que vous êtes le patron de ce
monsieur ne peut pas du tout vous n'êtes
pas de patron de ce monsieur dont vous
vendez pas des kebabs nom n'est pas
patron d'un kebab non sur site amnésie
quoi c'est votre patron pas bien sûr je
comprends pas ton et je relis mes fiches
mais vous avez 48 ans oui vous vivez à
enghien les bains
oui mais qu'est ce qui se passe après
car elle ou pas c'est moi et vous cette
action patron donc alors kamel répondait
des kebabs non je sens bien ce que je
batte ans qu'est ce que c'est que ces
histoires
alors est ce qu'on peut est ce que est
ce que vous connaissez juste ce
restaurant ce qu'on connaissait cette
chaîne de kebab connaissez sandra oh oui
oui je connais bien connaissez bien
cette chaîne mais là ça vous connaissez
oui je connais oui je manger du kebab
oui j'adore ça est ce que est ce que
vous avez fait un dossier
oui alors c'est quoi l'histoire parce
que je crois qu'un problème c'est quoi
j'ai fait un dossier
j'ai demandé j'ai demandé avec le groupe
fbh d'avoir une franchise
j'aimerais devenir franchisé de ce que
vous l'avez vous pas non j'ai pas eu de
réponse que vous avez été vous avez été
recalé et parcs à neige avait pas
beaucoup de moyens en tout cas pour
pouvoir ils vont 6000 euros c'est exact
ça vous étonne
c'est ça c'est vous avez 6000 euros donc
d'économies c'est ça et vous voulez
monter une chaîne un grand artiste et il
vous aurez calais parce qu'il faut il
faut un peu plus beaucoup plus d'argent
et puis bon bain et je sais que vous
mettez de côté tous les mois exactement
courant pouvoir c'est votre rêve d'avoir
cette franchir un cap
ça va ça avance bien ou pas c'est ça
avance ça va être long c'est d'ici
peut-être quatre ans parce que je sais
que ça coûte énormément d'argent une
fois thierry kebab ses environs une
motion cdc environ 500 mille euros c'est
ça cinq cent mille euros et will 500000
euros
oui oui je vous le dis ce kebab donc
vous reconnaissez mais alors donc
monsieur c'est pas votre patron je suis
désolé mais voilà on espère que ça va se
concrétiser pour vous
merci parce que moi en fait le problème
que j'ai je suis plus qui croire pascal
il dit que vous êtes votre patron on
vous a vu que 6000 oh je sais que c'est
480000 euros à peu près une franchise
comme ça et moi tout à l'heure comme
c'était sur mon chemin je suis passé
devant ce qu'est bad jeudi et y
ressembler à ça maintenant
arrête non
[Applaudissements]
non
merci est alors et non est ce que est ce
que tu as compris parce que tu as
compris
en fait je vais t'expliquer c'est que
c'est un un des magasins qui cartonne le
plus dans cette chaîne de kebab parce
que il est placé
c'est vraiment au coeur de paris i la
bastille c'est le kebab de basse il est
aujourd'hui mon chéri je te le dis à ces
toiles propriétaire
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais c'est toi qui es tu
ce soit
c'est toi propriétaire alors
je vais faire je vais faire venir les
faire venir
le pdg de la chaîne aqtim benotman merci
à king est magnifique ça va tu sais pas
ce que c'est c'est le numéro un ces
numéros le pdg deux enseignes nabab
kebab thiam aussi restent des nains
micro main et c'est vrai que c'est une
référence dans le domaine du kebab c'est
énorme
parce que vous me confirmer ce que donc
le kebab de bastille c'est le sien matin
c'est le sien bienvenue chez toi alors
vous lui offrez quoi en fait à kim ses
sauces et s'affranchissent à lui
maintenant c'est à lui maintenant de
fonds de commerce il à lui le droit
d'entrée à l'enp saigne ouais il est
exonéré en plus de redevances pendant en
vente
le contrat qui dure 10 ans montait à la
création jeu c'est un énorme de paix de
ce qu'on attend c'est énorme ce qu'ils
faisaient avant les vacances un gros
cadeau à nos frères dans tpm pitot est
un cadeau à 480 millions
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon chéri j'ai donc et vous allez mettre
du personnel à disposition il a tout
peut démarrer qu'on peut démarrer les
mains et peut dès maintenant
non alors tu peux démarrer demain on va
demeurer ensemble demain voilà deux ans
que je serai là j'ai pris mes vacances
on va commencer à travailler aussi dès
maintenant alors une folle être la clé
pour aller ouvrir demain freakley seront
là la clé du restaurant s'il vous plaît
les chéris ils sont là la clé du
restaurant s'il vous plaît pour la
roche-sur-yon autres et fissa et votre
soeur azita voilà c'est votre famille et
voilà donc tu as la clé du restaurant
demain tu seras avec ton nouveau taulier
parce que c'est le taulier lui c'est le
pdg voilà c'est le taulier est battue
que tu rêves qu'il a déposé mardi va
aller là voilà et maurane écrit avec mon
chéri
kamel tuer ton propre patron aujourd'hui
ce kebab il est à toi se donne la clé tu
la gardera voilà en tout cas merci
beaucoup je sais je sais plus quoi dire
alors je pensais qu est ce que je peux
dire parce que c'est énorme stress qu'il
a fait ce que c'est c'est juste fabuleux
parce que c'est un rêve c'est un vrai
acte de 2,2 d'être patron des patrons en
tout cas de cette chaîne parce que en
étant en étant dans la grande
distribution
je venais livrer un petit peu de temps
en temps et puis je regardais comment ça
fonctionnait c'est juste fabuleux acer
le pain il est exceptionnel la viande
année
si vous attend j'ai les clés je montrais
rossi je me demande un service
il y en a deux trois quand je vais
devoir me débarrasser parce que tu
pourra les prendre au jeu je prends tout
le monde
[Applaudissements]